today I'm gonna give you a sneak peek to
everything coming to Animal Crossing New
Horizons in the month of June from fish
bugs to special events plus how you can
start preparing right now people of the
internet retro reckons who are here your
guide to family-friendly content in the
world of video games so with May coming
to a close all of my non time-traveling
friends out there may be wondering
what's coming to Animal Crossing in the
month of June well I'm gonna show you
and also what you can start to do to
prepare today spoilers ahead I mean
would you have clicked on this video if
you didn't want to know what was coming
out in June anyway let's just be sure
and throw up one more spoilers ahead
just to be safe okay if you've been
anxiously awaiting the arrival of sharks
to your island and your wait is almost
up that's right my friends in the
northern hemisphere for the month of
June sharks finally make their way into
Animal Crossing New Horizons
but that's not all first of all there
are way more sharks than I expected
let's take a look at how many plus when
and where you can find them now here's a
little chart I put together using
information from the Animal Crossing dot
fandom wiki those folks over there do
fantastic work in compiling all this
information I'll toss a link to the wiki
down in the description below and also
include links to the images that I
created so you can save them on your
devices for easy access now as you can
see here we're getting not one not two
not three but four sharks this month
that's right guys four sharks go ahead
and let me know down in the comments
which shark you are hoping to catch
first well if you're in it for the money
then you'll want to set your sights on
the great white shark surprise surprise
right it'll fetch you a whopping 15,000
bells from nooks and even more if you
can catch siege a visiting whale shark
comes in at 13,000 sawshark
at 12,000 and hammerhead at 8,000 and
it's not only sharks there are plenty of
freshwater fish throughout the month of
June that will fetch you big-time bells
as well keep an eye out for the Dorado a
large fish only available in rivers from
4 a.m. to 9 p.m. just like the great
white Hill net you 15,000 bells there's
also the Arowana and arapaima both come
in 10,000 bells each did I say that
correctly
it's a buddy check that when it comes to
your ponds be on the lookout for a gone
are worth 6,000 bells June will also
bring along the sucker fish tilapia
piranhas giant snakehead saddled bashir
and ribbon he'll if I were you guys I'd
start collecting all the Manila clams
and crafting that fish bait as much as
you possibly can in preparation for all
these new sea animals were getting come
June I should also point out if you have
not yet caught a cherry salmon or char
be sure and do that this month as
they'll be leaving from the region come
July both of those are found in your
clifftop rivers so what about the bugs
bugs bugs we got bugs any bugs out there
when it comes to bugs for this month
you'll probably want to pay close
attention to what's leaving after June
is there are quite a few on the list the
good news is that you likely have all of
these already except for maybe the
peacock butterfly who you'll only find
flying near hybrid flowers if you're
having trouble with the violin beetle
you'll need to leave some tree stumps
around as they only spawn there you know
in making this video actually realize it
didn't have any tree steps on my island
so I had to go and chop down a few trees
but not dig up those stumps in order to
get those beetles the most notable bug
arrival of the month is the Goliath
beetle they can only be found on palm
trees between 5 p.m. and 8 a.m. they'll
bring in 8,000 bells should you decide
to sell the nukes the emperor butterfly
will be here as well along with the
rainbow stag Firefly drone beetle and
mosquito don't we all just love
mosquitoes also it's not a misprint on
the page the Firefly will only be around
for this month so be sure you set aside
at least one night to check that one off
your list so what else can you do to
prepare well the first thing I would do
is check your current critter pedia and
cross-reference that with the fish and
bugs that will be going away this month
aside from that you may also want to
check and see how many palm trees you
have around your island seeing that the
Goliath beetle will only spawn on palm
trees it may be pretty hard to find this
guy if you only have a couple of palm
trees on your island of course we
already mentioned grabbing as many of
those Manila clams as you can and using
them to craft bait as for special events
wedding season is upon us we're days
we'll be seeing reefs and syrus this
month and also get to take part in a
special wedding themed photo shoot on
harves island there should also be a bug
off on the third Saturday of the month
for the northern hemisphere so for this
year 2020 that will fall on June 20th
now should point out again guys that
most everything from today's bee
does specifically apply to the northern
hemisphere not everything but most
everything so if there's anybody out
there watching from the southern
hemisphere and he'd like to see me do a
similar video like this for the southern
hemisphere or maybe just even included
in this one go ahead and let me know
down in the comments below so I can know
how many of you are out there I don't
know about you guys but I am super
pumped to see new horizons in the summer
months and I can't wait for the Sharks
my son and I've been just counting down
the days for the Sharks